>>> IN OURL LEAD.
WE'RE HED IT TIME AN
PATH TO NORMALCY GETTING ENOU S
IMMUNITY.STER AND REPUBLICAN FR
LUNTT YI OO
APPEAL TO  VOTERD UGH REPUBLICA
HE TTOT WHY
THE 44%
THE VACCINE.
MATH TEAR OF THE
SHOT OUTWEIGHED THE FEAR OF THE
MEVACCINURLNS?ANDSALMOST, ALMOS
EVY. D THESE CUDN VACCINE, THEY.
>> T'SA HUGELOUD OF
QUESON COMES TO THATME.
>> A VERSS
D INY DIFFERENT A
WAYS.
>>'S B
OVERPLAYEDR US FOR WOULD AEAENG
MEDICINE.
NK LUNTZ JOINS MW.FRANK, WDOT O
WHY SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT'S A SCT A DIFFERENT
SAONT THEST VACCINATED
SO WHAS R
STOPPING THESE HESITANT
REPUBLICS FRET S NOT TO
DEMONIZE THEM ANTO
ANT  HESITATION ANW THAT THE MO
THE REASONS WHY I'VE BEEN DOCTOE
REACHING OUT T
WITHIN THE REPUBLICANS LED BY
BRADN OR UNDERSTANDS
ANDAN
CONCERNS AND WHEN WE FOUND OUT
O TODE CDCF ALL DO
AND A
FACT THAT THE PUBLIC RESPONDS TH
DODE THEM.DOT
DEMONSTRATE THAT YOU HEAR THEMAE
HEY LOVEAK POL
RATHER THAN POLITICIANS TELLING
IT COMES FRO MEMBER OR
THEIR OWN THENINFLUENCE.RSTHIS
NE FAVORITE SHOWS
LIFE"OKE TO THESE REPUBLICANSAN
FES AGO.BLICANITICIANSG CHRIS C
REPUBLICAN VOTERS, WHAT MADE
>> SENATORSI TALKING AUT THIS IE
YOU HOPE YOU DON'TEED IT BUT
YOU WANT IT JUST IN CASE OR
N McHY TALKINGBOISRAEL AND THE
WENSTROP ANPHASIZING THAT HE'SN
THE END IT'S DR.EEFACTE GAVE PE
WH YTHU  POLITICS FROM
I HAVE AT JOAVE TO BE L.
WILL ACRTRUMP OP
FOR GETTING THO
I HAVE A DREAM THAT DOOUMP WILL
CR J THE
VACCINES TO OF THELL CRECTORS AI
OWN DOCTORS DELIE REST OF
E THOUSANDS OF
K  OF THE 30CHTHEN LET
AT WOULD MOVE PELE GET PEOPLE'A
OF THE REPUBLICANS  THAAT HEAR
"THIS AMERICANY
ACTUALLY WENT OUT AND DID
E SHOT?
>> WE'VE STARTED TO CONTACTH
WE PUT OUT, IF YOU GO TO MY
TWITTER, Y C ASEE
THEIR ENATEAD AVE O
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT
ST OF THE DONE AT
.
>> NOWOUO DID OF REPUBLI DID D.
ASHEIR
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> LOST FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND
>> WHEN MY FRIEN AND
SHE TOLD UYONT  DON'T WTHN
>> WHEN IT APPEARED H I
HE SHO.
>> FIRST RNDINY LOHAT'S
COMING IN AND OUT AND WHAT THEY
>> BAGGI TAGGING, WOW. SEEMSS TA
THE VIRUS ISND HOW EASY THE SHO.
THEED O WORKN  HS  LIFE" WHEN C
AND THE SHOT.
HOW DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTTIK
DOCTORS IN THE F HOWTHEY REWORKI
BEHESTAGING BASEON WHA
>>IELKED ABOUT BRILLIANTLY W TH
ONE OF THEM WHO WAS HEALTH
ENDEUPD
THR ONE WHO WASICKER BUT
THT ITO RANDOM
AND IN THE END IT'S NOT AT THATD
E FDA.
IT'S THE YOU
PERSONALIZE IT T
MAFRKLAT'S WHY THEIR
WE ALL RESPECT, HE'S NOT T
MESER BECAUSE
IT'S BEELIWE'VE GOT TO KEEE POL
JAKE, THIS SEGMENT ITSELTO SAVEO
PEOPLE, A COUPLE
BECAUSE THEY WHAN IT
BECAUSE YOU'REING IT IAPOLITICA
FASHION.
YOU GAN WITH THE DOCTOR,  GUPTA
COME TO THE VOTERS THEMSELVE
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THE
PLNEE SO
THEY INSTEAD WILL SEEK MORD  WE
ALL HOWILL MAKE
THE RIGHT CIOK,  ACKNOWLEDGED
IN THE PAS GOTK , BUT I
DIDN'T DO THE RIGHT THINGS AND
SUFFERING FOR ITOW
NTHROUGH WHAT I WENT
I WANT THEM TOT
DECISIONS LYD
IND DE WE HAVETOS AWAY AETMEDIC
E MEDICINE SAK
IT'S SUC IMPTAN
BE HERE IS SAVING
LIVES.
THE GOAL HERE ISD
B NORMAL, ISEEN
K ABOUANY  OF OUON IN DAS
PEOPLE ARET
AND PEOPLEWHO LOVE THESE PEOE W
SKEPTICAL, WHAON THEM.
FRANK Z, YOU SO MUCH.
E YOUR TIME
CU
D AS REGARDLESS OF RACGETHER